STREAM IT RIGHT NOW THAT'S IT
FOR US TONIGHT.
THE MERCK HAPPY MONDAY EVERYBODY
.
MAN.
THERE ARE A LOT TO TALK ABOUT I
TODAY'S MONOLOGUE LIKE ANNA
NAVARRO IN FRONT A PLATE OF
CHURROS, STUDY THEM.
I LOVE CHURROS.
IT APPEARS MUSK MIGHT ACTUALLY
RESIGN AS TWITTER CEO.
I'M NOT SURE OF JACK DORSEY WIL
COME BACK, BUT HE WILL CONTINUE
NOT SHOWERING JUST IN CASE.
OVER THE WEEKEND, IF MUSK AS TH
TWITTER COMMUNITY, SHOULD I STE
DOWN AS HEAD OF TWITTER?
I WILL ABIDE BY THE RESULTS OF
THIS POLL.
IF ONLY BRIGHTER WITH IT THE
SAME POLE.
WE COULD DREAM.
TO THE MOSQUE FOLLOWED UP WITH
BE CAREFUL WITH WHAT YOU WISH A
BUT YOU MIGHT GET IT.
THAT'S SOMETHING I'M ON THE HAR
WAY WHEN IT WAS FOR GERALDO'S
FRIENDSHIP.
>> AFTER 17.5 MILLION VOTES THE
FINAL RESULT 57 PERCENT SAID YE
HE SHOULD STEP DOWN 43 PERCENT
SAID NO.
ALTHOUGH WERE STILL WAITING FOR
RESULTS FOR MARICOPA COUNTY.
BE MECCA DIDN'T SEE THAT ONE
COMING.
>> A PRETTY MIGHT WIDE MARGIN I
DON'T BECOME PLAYED THE DEMS FO
STEALING THIS ONE.
THEY STILL GOT PLENTY OF VOTES
FROM DEAD PEOPLE.
INCLUDING KEITH ALDERMAN.
>> SO WHO'S GOING TO REPLACE HIM
.
THIS SHOW THE FIVE AND THE
WEEKENDS AT TEACHING SPOT
WELDING TO THE SICK BRAXTON FOR
THE ORPHANAGE.
I HATE CHARITABLE WORK IT'S TO
GIVING BUT THERE ARE SOME
AVAILABLE PEOPLE OUT THERE
HUNTER BIDEN BE HONEST, HE CAN
MAKE IT RAIN IN THE BOARDROOM
AND TO THE VIP ROOM.
HE'LL KNOCK UP YOUR STOCK PRICE
LIKE A PIERCE STRIPPER IN 2-INC
HEELS.
BECAUSE HE DID.
JIMMY BELLA BECAUSE EVERYONE
HATES HIM ALREADY.
GREGORY.
THANK YOU SB MACDONALD TRUMPETS
FACE IT BEING TWITTER CEO IS AL
THE FUN OF BEING PRESIDENT
WITHOUT BEING PRESIDENT.
STILL TORTURE THE MEDIA WITHOUT
HAVING TO SPELL JIM ACOSTA'S
HORRIBLE BREATH AND A TRUMPET
LESSON FILTER THAT MIKE WOULD
FISH AQUARIUM THOSE GUYS SURE
ARE GOOD AT FLIPPING UPSIDE DOWN
.
HOW ABOUT BRIAN KILL ME?
WHO KNOWS HOW HE'LL HANDLE
TWITTER BUT IT CAN'T BE WORSE
THAN HIS LIFE.
>> I KNOW.
THAT'S TERRIBLE HILLY CRETIN IF
SHE CAN HER, SHE WON'T HAVE TO
MURDER.
GOOD ONE.
ALSO HAPPENING OVER THE WEEK IN
THE LATEST BATCH OF TWITTER
FILES WERE DUMPED SHOWING THE
FBI RATTLED TWITTER IS X OVER
NOT REMOVING STUFF THAT UPSET
THEM GENERAL HAZMAT VALUE
BETWEEN THE REVELATIONS QUOTE
TWITTER'S CONTACT WITH THE FBI
WAS CONSTANT AND PERVASIVE AS I
IT WERE A SUBSIDIARY.
HE SHOULD BETWEEN JANUARY 2020
AND NOVEMBER 2022 THEM OVER 150
E-MAILS BETWEEN THE FBI AND
TWITTER EXECS AND MANY WERE
BEQUEST BY THE FBI TOO TAKE
ACTION ON ELECTION
MISINFORMATION.
IF IT INVOLVED A CHOKED TWEETS
AND LOAF ON THE ACCOUNTS.
AND WITH THE FBI INVESTIGATING
JOKES ONE THING IS FOR SURE.
HE LEFT A TRAIL WHEN A WITH
TREVOR NOVA'S ACCOUNT ALONE.
AT ONE POINT AS MANY AS 80 FBI
AGENTS WERE TASKED WITH
PATROLLING THE SITE.
DEMANDING ANYTHING THAT DID NOT
LIKE BE FLAGGED OR TAKEN DOWN.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE THEY HAD EXTRA
TIME.
I GUESS THEY GOT SICK OF PREDAW
RATES OF TRUMP AND HIS FRIENDS.
I WONDER IF THE SAME AGENT SINC
CONSIDERED EXTORTION A CRY
BECAUSE I SUGGESTING THAT HOW
ABOUT THIS NOT NOSE PIMPLY FACE
BRAT GROUP PUBLISHED EILAND'S
PRIVATE JET INFO ON TWITTER.
HERE HE IS ON PUBLIC ACCESS
CHANNEL BACK IN FEBRUARY TALKIN
ABOUT WHAT IT WILL TAKE TO MAKE
THEM GO AWAY.
>> WHICH ARE CURRENT DEMAND?
RELATIVE TO MASS, BUT LET MAKE
FOR YOU TO GO AWAY AND STOP THIS
?
>> US TO LET US GET TEST LEFT
FOR $50,000.
NOT GOING TO UP IT NO NEED TO.
>> AWESOME TERRY HAVEN'T SEEN A
SHAKEDOWN THAT BAD SINCE
SECURITY AT THE CAESAR'S PALACE
BUFFET.
HAD MICHAEL MORRIS STAND ON HIS
HEAD.
TO SEE IF ANY GLAZED HYMNS WOUL
FALL OUT OF HIS POCKETS.
WILL THE FBI BE ON THAT COULD
STILL?
THEIR BUSY INTERROGATING
GRANNIES FROM JANUARY 6 OR A
TEAM TO HARASS MICHAEL AND DEL.
>> FORTUNATELY THAT GUY WILL
SLEEP THROUGH ANYTHING.
MEANWHILE MORE FILES THEY
PREEMPTIVELY MINE IS IN THE
RELEVANT IS THAT SHE WAS LINKED
TO AN INTEL OPERATION THAT'S
NEWS.
I WONDER WHAT THE MEDIA COVERAG
OF THAT WAS LIKE.
IT'S MUST BE FOOTAGE FROM THE
WNBA PLAYOFFS.
CAN BET THEY COVERED PRECIOUS
JOURNALIST VIOLATING TERMS OF
IN CASE YOU NOTICE, NO ONE
NOTICED.
NO ONE CARES THE FACT THAT THE
MEDIA DOES CARE SHOWS YOU HOW
DESPERATE THEY ARE FOR SOMETHIN
TO FILL THE TRUMP SIZED HOLE
THAT 45 LEFT BEHIND.
NOW WHO THOSE THE WHOLE?
ITS MUSK.
TICKET LOOK ADAM SCHEPP.
IT MIGHT JUST PROJECTILE
VOMITING.
SHIFT TREATED ELI MUSK CALLS
HIMSELF A FREE SPEECH ABSOLUTIS
TO JUSTIFY TURNING A BLIND AND
AN TWITTER BUT WHEN JOURNALIST
REPORT UNFAVORABLE NEWS THERAPY
AND WITHOUT WARNING THE DEVOTIO
OF FREE SPEECH IS APPARENTLY NO
THAT ABSOLUTE BUT THE HYPOCRISY
IS.
MUSK TWEETED BACK QUOTE
THANKFULLY YOU LOSE YOUR
CHAIRMANSHIP VERY SOON.
THE BEST PART PREMATURE
COPULATION.
AT THE END OF THE TWEET WITH
YOUR BRAIN WAS TOO SMALL.
THAT'S THE BEST PART THE IRONY
IS OUT OF SHIP SPRING IS TOO
SMALL TO LET THE SMALL BRAIN
STOP HIM.
IT'S WHETHER THE DEMOCRATS KEEP
HIM AROUND THE GET STEPCHILD
MADE EVERYONE ELSE IN THE PARTY
UP LIKE GENIUSES I WOULDN'T
BLAME HIS PARENTS
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS
HE WILL KILL YOU WITH KINDNESS,
A CLUB CALLED HIM THE HOUR WELL
BECAUSE IT THEY HEAR HIS NAME
AND ASKED WHO?
WHO?
>> I ALWAYS FELT BAD WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT THE STUFF YOU WORK
FOR THE GOVERNMENT.
YOU KILLED PEOPLE YOU CAN KILL
ME YOU CAN KEEP ME AROUND JUST
BECAUSE YOU MAKE ME LAUGH.
YOU DON'T GET RENTAL THAT.
>> OR DISGRUNTLED.
>> IT'S ALL WE HAVE TIME FOR.
DRIVE SAFELY.
IT'S NOT RECENT IT'S BEEN
DEVELOPED LIKE THIS.
HERE'S THE FBI SHOULD HAVE
CONTACT WITH COMPANIES.
A VARIETY OF COMPANIES IN A
VARIETY OF SECTORS INCLUDING
TWITTER.
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING IN
CONCERT IS WHEN THEY IDENTIFY A
HOSTILE ELEMENT THAT IS USING
OUR SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS OVER
THEIR OWN GOOD.
THEY SHOULD WORK WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO IDENTIFY THAT
JUST LIKE THEY SHOULD WORK WITH
THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO GET BEST
PRACTICES IN CYBERSECURITY.
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS OBVIOUSLY
WRONG IT'S POLITICAL.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING--TH
POINT AS BIAS HAS INVADED THIS
PROCESS.
>> AND ONCE YOU LOSE IT.
I'VE LIVED AND WORKED OVERSEAS
IN A VARIETY OF NASTY PLACES
WHERE EVERY TIME THERE IS A
CHANGE IN GOVERNMENT OR A NEW
DICTATOR, THEY WHOLESALE CHANGE
THE INTEL ORGANIZATION.
>> AND YOU CAN'T LIVE IN AN
ENVIRONMENT LIKE THAT.
WE DO NOT WANT THAT.
THE BUREAU THE AGENCY THEY ALL
HAVE TO BE POLITICAL.
THE ONLY OTHER THING I HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT THIS IS INVOLVES MUSK
IS HONEST TO GOD THE ANGST THAT
THE PROGRESSIVE LIBERALS ARE
SHOWING OVER THE REALIZATION
THAT TWITTER IS NO LONGER THERE
EXCLUSIVE PLAYGROUND IF I COULD
BOTTLE THAT ANGST AND SURVEYED
OVER ARTISANAL ICE AND DRINK IT
ON A WARM SUMMER'S NIGHT ON MY
PORCH I'D BE THE HAPPIEST DUDE
WOULD YOU DO THAT SHIRTLESS.
THINKING ABOUT IT RIGHT NOW IT'
DISGUSTING.
IT IS AN INTERESTING POINT AT
LIKE THEY DIDN'T TAKE THE BALL
AND GO HOME WE TOOK THE BOTTLE
FROM HIM MIKE IS POINTING OUT I
MAY THAT'S WHY MUSK IS REPLACIN
TRUMP IN THAT VEIN THAT MOST
HATED MAN ON EARTH.
WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT ALL THIS.
>> I THINK ALL ABOUT I DO SINCE
THEY KICKED TRUMP OFF A LOT OF
HIS FOLLOWERS LEFT ALSO IF YOU
GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE CONTENT
ON LETTER IT'S A BUNCH OF PEOPL
HIGH-FIVING PEOPLE NOW THEY ALL
WANT TO GO TO POST PEOPLE DID
NOT KNOW WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
>> ALL BASED ON THE FACT THAT
YOU BE BABYLON BFI WAS EVER
GOING TO BE A BILLIONAIRE AND
THAT'S HOW ARBITRARY I WOULD US
MY MONEY.
YOU BID MY FAVORITE ACCOUNT TO
UNBIND YOUR COMPANY.
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
ISN'T IT WEIRD THE FBI AS
TROLLING TWITTER FOR JOKES.
>> HE'S GOT A MILLION OF THEM
WHEN I WAS A LITTLE KID WE USED
TO GO TO SIX FLAGS THAT THERE
WERE THESE GUYS WITH THE FBI HO
FEDERAL BIKINI INSPECTOR.
YOU MIGHT NOT GET THE RECORDS
YOU CANNOT GET ON THE RIDES AT
SIX FLAGS AND THOSE US ON THE
LINES--GREAT AVENGER.
>> BUT STICK WITH ME A. TRITES
TO THOSE GUYS WITH OUR UNTIL
MORE THAN THE FBI AND THAT SAID
I DON'T WANT TO BEG ON THE INTE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE IF MY LAPTOP
GETS DISCOVERED I GOT BIG
PROBLEMS I'M CARRYING A VIAL OF
ARSENIC RIGHT NOW JUST IN CASE.
>> BUT THIS IS WHERE I'M HAVING
A HARD TIME WITH THE LAW MUSK
BECAUSE THE THING HE WAS TRYING
TO EXPOSE THE CORRUPTION ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF OWNERSHIP BUT BY
ALIGNING THEMSELVES WITH
POLITICAL POSITIONS HE'S
ALLOWING TO JUSTIFY TURNING A
BLIND EYE TOWARD THE WORK HE IS
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
WHEN HE IS SAYS FIRE FOUND SHE
THAT'S POLITICAL IT A LOT OF
PEOPLE JUMP IN AND ARE LIKELY T
EVEN HAVE TO LISTEN TO THIS
ANYMORE IT'S WHITENING RING
STRONGMAN STOP I THINK ON ONE
AND IT'S GOOD BUT I THINK ON TH
OTHER AND HE'S DISCREDITING
HIMSELF IN THE PROCESS SO HE
SHED.
>> I THINK THAT PART OF THAT IS
THE RED PELLING IS HAPPENING A
PUBLIC EVERYTHING HE DOES IS IN
PUBLIC MUCH LIKE YOU AND
CONGRATULATION HER COMMUNITY
SERVICE HAS BEEN COMPLETED.
>> WHO DO YOU THINK.
OBVIOUSLY HE'S GOING TO STEP
ASIDE IT WOULD'VE NEVER DONE A
TWITTER POLL IF HE KNEW IF HE
DID NOT KNOW THE OUTCOME.
HE KNEW WHAT IT WAS GOING TO BE
EXPLOITED THAT OPPORTUNITY WHO
SHOULD BE THE PERSON?
SHOULD'VE BE ANOTHER VISIONARY
OR BE SOMEBODY BUT THAT A SINGL
IDEA LIKE JIMMY?
IT SHOULD BE SOMEBODY THAT WE'V
NEVER HEARD OF.
SO THAT YOU CAN'T GET MAD ABOUT
IT.
I WILL GO TO THE PROM WITH YOU.
>> I WOULD DIE FOR THAT.
I GET WHY HE DOES NOT WANT TO D
IT.
YET HE IT.
ALREADY ONE.
LIKE WHEN I BE PAUL BOWSER AND
N64 KINDA STOPPED PLAYING AT
THAT'S WHAT YOU MAKE GREAT
PRESIDENT AND BE LIKE VOTE FOR
ME I REALLY WANT TO WIN AND I'L
LEAVE YOU ALONE.
BUT THAT'S WHAT YOU NEED YOU
NEED SOMEBODY PEOPLE WILL TRY
HARD WHOEVER IT IS EVERYONE WIL
DO A DEEP DIVE AND BE LIKE THIS
PERSON JUST AS POCAHONTAS AND
THE SIX GRADE AT THEIR RACIST
APPEAR THEY CAN'T DO THIS IN A
MATTER WHO YOU ARE THEY HAVE TO
FIND THE MOST BORING PERSON IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD TO RUN THINGS.
>> HAS YOU TURN ON FOX AND
FRIENDS BE MACK BOOM.
I'M JOKING IT'S A WONDERFUL SHOW
.
THERE'S SOMETHING WITH WHAT HE'
DOING RIGHT NOW THE TWITTER FIL
IS RELEASED THERE'S NO WAY HE'S
GONNA TURN IT EVEN ELON MUSK I
GIVE THEM A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
THINGS I DON'T KNOW HOW HE MAKE
IT A PROFITABLE COMPANY.
THERE MAY BE SOME ELEMENT IF HE
CAN SHOW A HUGE DEGREE OF
MALFEASANCE, THAT WASN'T
DISCLOSED BY THE BUSINESS, THER
MAY BE A CHANCE I DON'T KNOW.
>> I WILL BE STILL TWEETS.
HE'S A GREAT LEADER.
I DON'T REALLY CARE THAT HE HAS
A POLITICAL COMMENT HERE OR
THERE.
WE DON'T NEED THE DAVID SOUTER
OF TWITTER.
I LIKE PEOPLE WHO HAVE AN
OPINION LET'S HAVE ONE.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT MATTERS WHO
DOES IT SIT OR WELL-KNOWN, I
THINK NOW WITH HIS OWNERSHIP,
PEOPLE ARE NERVOUS ABOUT WHAT
COMES NEXT.
WE ARE SOON INSERTED SHADOW
BANNING HAS TO GET IT DENIGRATE
PEOPLE DO IT TO OUR FACES IT
TURNS OUT THEY WERE DOING IT
BEHIND OUR BACKS ON SOCIAL MEDI
AND PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT
GREG, ELON MUSK HAS ACCESS TO A
MUST START REVEALING DIRECT
MESSAGES.
>> UP NEXT WITH SHAKEEL FIELD B
GRADE WHEN